[Music]
just write your band now from the view
that's a lifetime that's a lifetime ban
it comes right what did you do they got
you Oh Barbara Walters banned you right
from the top honey don't mess with my
she will cut a [ __ ] all right oh yeah
don't you see why you were banned yeah
all right so once I was co-hosting the
view because that really is actually
you've done that show it's actually a
fun environment because those crazy
[ __ ] you don't know what's gonna stay
I had just come from doing Howard Stern
and Howard was joking about how he
wanted to bang Barbara Walters and so
then I went into the dressing room and
there were about 15 people there and I
said hey Barbara just you know Howard
still wants to bang you you've still got
it
you might want to grab some KY and make
a night of it and then and then Barbara
Walter
are you picturing please tell me you're
picturing Howard Stern my soul left my
body like 30 seconds ago
I'm hovering above the rafters right now
looking down so I said the barber you
might want to grab some KY and then she
said I prefer Astroglide and I thought
that was so cute and charming that she
said that that I put it in my next bravo
stand-up special Oh which she did not
appreciate oh so she can sit at
backstage but didn't want ever people
she said in front of 15 people in the
hair and makeup room which to me is you
know yeah it's it's game but I thought
it was kind of cool that barbers like
still got it going on and she's using
Astroglide she may have been trying to
cut a deal with the KY is going to say
yeah that this is why I cannot have
celebrity guests on my show
you're now banned from here by no